well my wife has trip to Obama
I had a few instructions on what to do
when I got the hair and how to behave
other things all to do with Aikido
or I haven't
thought about was just how Hardy the
training physically was
it was an August when I arrived
in September
and leaving without a sensei
to go to Italy for seminar and then on
to England
where I didn't mind him to teach a
seminar
so being like a new child with a new
tire
I got to Obama
and um
there was lots of students from all over
Japan coming on a daily basis
since he said he would teach two extra
classes
so where there'd be one in the morning
early
and one in the evening
there would be two extra classes fitted
in
so the Heat and the humidity being
extremely difficult to cope with
I got fit before I went and bought a
bicycle sideboard
got myself extremely fit lost two
standing weights
and I was ready for the challenge
or something I thought everything I'd
done
was for the fitness to man to excel
because I was taking my fifth and
taijitsu test while being an environment
what I didn't know was
he was also going to test me from in the
first week
for my fourth and Mercury
and after in the third week I was there
he tested me for my fifth
and Final
booty monster
Scrolls
known as
so everything I'd done and prepared
was for
stamina
for physical training while in the dojo
all of a sudden there was a celebration
where
is something to hear a Sensei had carved
a wonderful wooden head
I don't know what it was it was
I'll call that Dragon because attacks to
the Head they had this massive length of
cloth
Callum cloth and people go under that
so that they move the cloth as if the
dragon is going along the road
at the same time
people are behind a count on these large
small long time Wheels
and this card is brought out from
festive
gatherings
and in this particular case
he sat in there
and we set off at midday
and he would play these drums
while
the uchigashi
from around the world
all the different countries
we would be pushing this cart all over
the Obama Village stopping at their best
places
and
going to people's houses
where we would do a dance with the
dragon
outside of the house
and people would come out and view this
little did I know that it was my turn to
get under there
the dragon's head and it was very heavy
but you have a wooden whale bar
inside this head where you can hold it
and you turn it and curve and go up and
down and dip and do all the virtual
things
that you do
well I'm a member is
being completely out of character
and the sound and the beating drum
the heat of the day
and I was
moving and we come to this house of
course not too busy to look to see who's
there you're just doing your best
and this dance is almost like being in a
Charmed state
there's
Chance by some people
sit and do charms
others sit in trance
talk to spirits on the other side or say
of Life have passed on
this chance where
you allow your spirit guide to use your
voice box
and I speak to those in front of them
and tell them
show them things they may answer
questions or they may just give words of
wisdom
to those who are prepared to listen
some go into trance by dancing the
whirling damages
I don't know what country they're from
but they don't in spinning in small
groups spending spending until they
become in trials
so there's various ways of being in
trance
but my experience at this moment in time
under the dragon's head
I was tired I was exhausted with all the
training
the Heat
midday setting off and it didn't end
until after nine I believe it was about
9 30 at night
tremendous hate humidity
and pushing a solid wooden
cart
that was more like a massive
cage
always
NC was playing these drums so he had a
task as well all day for the next nine
hours
with very little stops
we didn't have time for stocks apart
from taking over who would be in the
dragon's head
my famous
apart from me and to polish my ego was
after my time in the dragon's head
one of the Japanese said and I I swapped
over and went to the back of the car to
push again
that they were side effects his wife
and her neighbors
house that I put down the dance
now I've never ever done this dance or
even understood it before apart from
seeing on television the Chinese do the
Dragon Dance
so I can only say that I must have been
in a Triumph State at this point
she commented it was the best Dragon
Dance she'd sing
and dragon
there was many of them I don't know how
many
at the end of the evening were all
gathered
in the center of Iran
and it's like a small town now more than
a village but
they call it a village
and they all formed a circle a little
bit like
some countries would have
uh perhaps Gypsy Caravans organ
where the horses would slowly pull the
Caravans into like a horseshoe Circle
those are all these other cards and we
all linked up at this one point
until then I had no idea that there was
others out there
I thought it was just
ourselves
so I hope you enjoyed this story
and I hope also while I'm telling them
and just let the new focus on the show
to see and now the objects within the
frame
but perhaps
I can transmit these pictures to you as
I speak
and therefore you'll be in a child state
it's not such a hard thing to do
and we do it without thinking we often
become in a we could call it daydreaming
state
you occupied Minds so you're watching
and listening
as somebody's talking but your mind is
elsewhere
so I hope you've enjoyed this story
and I'd like you to if you play again
too
place your own colors on the dragon's
head
the wooden carving
it's the large wooden dragon's head
they look quite scary
and perhaps it with your eyes closed you
can imagine how you would dance and dig
and free yourself from all your normal
inhibitions that you may have
and hangouts
trying to do the correct thing to
conform
I shall carry on with this series of
talking
because
in the hopes that some of you will enjoy
the other side the deeper side
to understanding
the osency
found and followed
and I didn't know this at the time but
as the years have gone by I've realized
that physical timing and physical seeing
is not enough
develop true
attacking musu ID
you have to be sensitive enough
to feel the person before they arrive
to know
what they are sentencing themselves
as they sense it
go and meet them and meet their energy
their order
doesn't have fear does it have
positivity
if you know the answer in advance
you can blend and balance whatever they
have
and then you and then become one
therefore they can never harm you
because
you are then you become them the same as
dancing with the dragon's head never
danced before
but to find a rhythm that is not you but
the Rhythm that is required at the time
thank you for listening